and now let me introduce Sam ryskamp our
outstanding senior man Sam comes from
Caledonia Michigan he will graduate with
a major in mathematics his thesis topic
get this is analyzing coupled point
process models for gang rivalry dynamics
gang rivalry dynamics matha tized Sam is
a member of the Kappa mu epsilon the
national math maddox honorary society
the Sigma Pi Sigma the national physics
honorary and Omicron Delta Kappa as well
as a representative of the hillsdale
college student Federation he was an
honors intern for the FBI in lansing
michigan since August 2014 assisting
agents with analysis for
counterterrorism bank robbery and
violent crime investigations prior to
that he served as honors intern at the
FBI in Washington DC he was a voluntary
volunteer coordinator for the goal
program here at Hillsdale a research
assistant in the president's office here
and a student ambassador in the
admissions office along with numerous
other work experiences throughout his
time at Hillsdale College let's
congratulate and welcome Sam ryskamp are
outstanding
Thank You mr. blow to all the faculty
families and friends welcome to this
spring parents weekend luncheon thank
you for inviting me to speak about
coupled point process differential
equations so when dr. on comes and
speaks next I expect he will probably
say something about the Winston
Churchill class that I took with him in
the fall during the class he liked to
make fun of me surprise but he liked to
make fun of me for my apparent hesitancy
in speaking up in class because in that
class I tended to abide by the proverb
even a fool is considered wise when he
keeps his mouth shut this strategy
seemed to work in the short run but the
very fact that I'm standing before you
today is evidence that he has called my
bluff and has forcibly removed from me
any possibility of further keeping my
mouth shut so here I am during fall
break of my sophomore year my friends
and I decided it would be fun to travel
up to the Upper Peninsula and so we
rented a house up there and we we
started driving the 15 of us piled into
three cars and drove all the way up
there we didn't know exactly where we're
going and it was dark and in the Upper
Peninsula you don't really have cell
phone service but we had directions we
knew it was going to be the fourth house
on the right so we drove down we found
the first house on the right and drove a
few more miles because this is the Upper
Peninsula found the second house on the
right drove a few more miles found the
third and fourth house right next to
each other but the fourth house looked
kind of like the pictures that we saw
and we tried the front door and it was
unlocked so we assume must be the right
place and we we did what college kids do
we pillaged it we uh we raided the
fridge we started claiming bedrooms and
cleaning bathrooms and then all of a
sudden someone tried a door that hadn't
been tried yet when they went inside
there was clothes lying on the floor
and not just well that's a clue and so
we started looking around and we noticed
a few more clues like why was there food
in the fridge at the same time a car
pulled into the driveway next door and
it was our landlord asking us if we
found the house next door okay so at
that point we decided to abandon ship we
ran out of the house and uh yeah we just
ran through some stranger's house in the
Upper Peninsula fortunately it didn't
turn out being a stranger it was our
landlords house and he was very gracious
and forgiving but from this story I
learned a valuable lesson no matter how
far away from civilization you build
your house you are never safe from
interruptions this is also this is a
very important lesson and it's also a
lesson that I've learned repeatedly at
Hillsdale College if you haven't noticed
our campus is quite small it's about one
square block into this block we squeeze
over 1400 energetic restless and
sociable college students so in my four
years here I have systematically tested
every possible place to study on this
block and have yet to find one that is
impenetrable to interruptions nowhere is
safe even your bedroom that final refuge
from the cacophony of college life is
subject to random invasions at 3am by
screaming young men wearing clown masks
in Simpson that's called bedtime patrol
at first those constant interruptions
irritated me why would anyone design an
institution of learning like this I
wondered I thought education was
supposed to be about reading and
meditating about quiet contemplation how
do you read good books when there's
nowhere to read now I understand why
monasteries have walls I thought but
what I did not understand then but I
know now is that in those interruptions
in those moments where you're planning
on doing work but don't that's where the
real work of Hillsdale College takes
place it is not in spite of the
interruptions but through them that
hillsdale college does what it does best
learning to live well the development of
hearts and minds the formation of
character is a kind of learning that
does not take place primarily in a
classroom it is learned like a language
by immersion if you want to learn
Spanish you can spend years and years
and years taking three credit classes or
you can spend a semester in Spain living
among those who have spent years
practicing and for whom Spanish is
second nature best is to do both
similarly if you want to learn how to
live well you can't study it in a
classroom and you should but you must
also live among those who speak this
language of character fluently you must
talk with them watch movies with them
laughs debate prank tease share
bathrooms invade houses and live with
them you must help them change their
tires and build snowmen in their showers
you must have meaningful and thoughtful
conversations with them and not just
with them your fellow students but also
with your professors with the deans with
Chris who works at Bon Appetit with char
and Don and Trudy and sue the
long-suffering Simpson cleaning ladies
and it is in these moments that we
aren't looking during the interruptions
that friendships are forged and through
friendships character
ultimately Hillsdale College is an
institution that exists not just for
study but also for service we are
community of servants as Shelley was
talking about a partnership of men and
women who challenged each other to live
lives of selfless service to our
families community country most
importantly to our Heavenly Father a
life of love combined with learning is
the final purpose of Hillsdale College
let me illustrate this and close with
one final story sometime ago my father
went through some health troubles he is
currently doing better but for a while
it was a scary time during this time my
father took a Saturday afternoon to do
something special he took my younger
brother and I SAT us down on the couch
with pens and notebooks in hand and told
us everything he never wanted us to
forget every minute of that afternoon is
forever ingrained in my memory but one
thing in particular stands out in my
mind my father the man for whom I have
more respect than anyone in the world
having weighed everything he had
accomplished in his long not uneventful
life told us that his greatest
investment in contribution to the world
was his two sons the two young men
sitting here on the couch across from
him it's a weighty thing to be the life
contribution of a great man my father
demonstrated what it means to live a
life of service being poured out for the
sake of others all of us in this room
Shelley was talking about our the
undeserved recipients of the service of
thousands of men and women who we will
never meet but sacrificed time talent
and treasure that we could have this
building this food and these friends it
is humbling to be part of this
partnership in the words of Jesus Christ
the one who gave the ultimate sacrifice
to give us an eternal gift of much
greater worth than even our education
but whoever would be great among you
must be your servant and whoever would
be first among you must be your slave
even as the Son of man came not to be
served
but to serve this is what I hope that I
and all my fellow students have learned
at hillsdale college someday many years
from now when all the students have
moved beyond Hillsdale College I hope
and pray that we will never have moved
beyond living a life of service god
bless